Ngày mùng tăng tư i ra ngay cơm bố để xuất mời điểm nhằm chấm rất của xung độ với Mỹ và Israel.
Chúng đau nhấn mạnh các điều kiện linh qua đến Anh Ninh, Hạp Nhân và Tinh Tế, Chỉ Tinh Nilsau, Một, Bình Wintak,
Mỹ về cám kết thung tấn công quân sự đồ vị ràng, Hàing, Thuy nhận quên kiểm soán quý ràng đồ vị ở biển hông một.
Bà, chấm nhận quên làm sao uống rình đi của yên ràng, Bốn, bại bỏ tất cả các lệnh trường phạm chính.
Bại bỏ tất cả các lệnh trường phạm thử cấp, sấu chấm rất hiệu lực của tất cả các nghị quế của bỏ ăn li của bài.
Chấm rất hiệu lực của tất cả các nghị quế của quân ăn lượng quên tự của tẩy ai ai ai.
Tấm, Bộ thương thì thạch tru ý văn, chính Mỹ về xuất toàn bộ lực lượng chính đông rất hỏi khu bực trung đông và mời.
Chấm rất dau trang trên mọi mặt trận, Tế cả với các lượng thẳng chiến hồi giá hồi li bằng.
Hồi đông ăn niên cua ra tối cả ở răng tru sang, mười điểm này sẽ tạo thành cơ sở pháp li của tế trong một thỏ thận toàn dẹp.
Firm Mỹ thì chưa đưa ra phản huy chính thức về tòm bộ cái điều kiện, săm nếu tế mẹn nền xuất và coi đây là cơ sở để tức thảo luật.
Thật đều mới tình nhận chẳng chất thấy Washington vẫn duy trì khả năng đảm phán, với việc ấn đình của đối thoại và ngày 1 mời tháng tư tại Pakistan.